de petites boîtes de 9 à 36 mètres
carrés fait en plastique on y
travaillait on y dort mais aussi depuis
sept ans julien recours accumulent ces
modules témoin de l'histoire des trésors
qui sentent bon les années 60 où les
loisirs se développe l'idée c'était de
vraiment de réinventer la manière la
manière d'habiter et de pouvoir aussi
concevoir qu'on pouvait prendre chaque
maison qui est industrialisé la mode sur
un camion si on voulait la mettre à la
montagne dont la meute et le montage on
voulait la mettre sur le sable on
pouvait aussi dans sa collection il y à
des pépites comme cette maison bull à
six coques de jambes à jamais ma ne
valent ou alors ce bureau coquille créé
par gérard grandval pour cacharel le
local on lui met en fait été hachée
bornes et il fallait qu'il le rende un
petit peu plus funky et il avait décidé
en fait de la jouer un peu comme des
sous mariniers et que quand les gens
venaient travailler le matin en fait les
rentrées dans leur capsule qui est
alimenté en air et tout sera de ses
pièces il en reste quelques exemplaires
aujourd'hui trouvé grâce ou rencontrer
au bouche à oreille mais à chaque fois
ils sont en mauvais état en général
quand les modules à rêver sont en très
mauvais état ça fait plusieurs années
qu'ils sont sous la pluie et la première
étape consiste à les assainir avant de
les réparer puisqu'ils sont du coup
gorgée d'eau donc déjà on les met à
l'abri on attend que l'eau s'écoule
vraiment complètement avant d'entamer
une restauration objets d'art patrimoine
architectural comme cette entrée type
d'une piscine tournesol ses trouvailles
ont leur place dans les musées alors il
faut constituer des archives c'est
important de documenter en termes de
photos de vidéos si on a pu rencontrer
les architectes si on a pu rencontrer
les fabricants des ingénieurs plus on
offre un projet complet on va dire une
étude et une recherche vraiment aboutie
sur l'objet plus on peut
prétendre à exposer dans des endroits
intéressants d'autres collectionneurs
privés lui rachète ces modules il
réfléchit à les mettre en location